what's happening there reject nation
greg and john here we're going to watch
from the heavy spoilers channel
he's going to love this
he's going to love it
where's that crikey pool ah dad jokes
coming your way
pool uh sweep your chimney or weirdo
will hawkeye trailer break down today
let's get into action subscribe to his
channel if you haven't done so already
he's just a a great lad i must say
[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka mo hawkeye and i'm
gonna do whatever it takes until people
finally realize that's a really good
joke yeah now the first trailer for
hawkeye is now here and in this video
we're going to be breaking down all the
easter eggs things you missed hidden
details and also how it compares to the
comics
because of that there will be heavy
spoilers so if you don't want anything
ruined then i recommend that you check
out now make sure you aim for that
thumbs up button and hit it and it turns
out you get double points for hitting
the subscribe button so yeah go go and
do that as well now without the way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into hawkeye
okay so the last full appearance of
hawkeye happened in avengers end game
when we found out that he'd been
operating under the name the ronin
during the five years between the blip
and the snap moving in the shadows as a
gangster killing vigilante he'd build up
quite a reputation and this will likely
be brought into the show due to the
kinds of villains that show up in the
source material do they call him ronin
in the actual movie i don't remember
them it actually says the name i don't
think so not that i recall i don't
recall them
clearly
just comment below and correct us
tell us we're idiots the story will be
heavily based on the hawkeye comic run
from 2013 and in that we follow clint as
he trains up as proto-jk bishop who also
goes under the name hawkeye set to
release on november 24th the series will
follow the pair as they fight crime
across the marvel universe in what will
probably be the most grounded disney
plus show so far i mean i hope it can be
grounded for what the mcu is you know
you say grounded and it's exactly the
most granted but when it comes to like
the matt fraction run that was one of
the things that was heavily embraced
about it was how a lot of times before
that hawkeye was a character who they
they tried making seem like larger than
life or more super heroic than he
actually is
where they really embrace the fact that
he is very human and i mean just from
the image alone that you were seeing
here you see he's like all bandaged up
and everything he's got the hearing aid
piece here in the trailer showing that
he is very human in terms of going
grounded that's what i'm hoping they
really delve in with specifically clint
barton is portraying that side of him
the very human angle that he's not one
of the superheroes you know despite the
fact he's got insane accuracy embrace
that street level now the first thing i
want to talk about is florence bew who
will be reprising her role in the series
as elena belova black without ended with
val going to her and telling her that
clint was responsible for her sister's
death i think that in the series she
will obviously seek revenge and become
one of the major antagonists for it but
that by the end she will learn the truth
about what really happened and this will
make her switch sides potentially we
might even see her join the avengers in
this series and it is possible that
she'll take over the black widow mantle
much like how she did in the comics and
then she and kate will go to budapest
they are either going to be segwaying
into young avengers which seems ideal or
west coast adventures i'm hoping for
west coast avengers i know i said in our
trailer reaction at the very tail end of
it we need some la-based superheroes man
the east coast does not need as much
help anymore we got so many people
heroes start we need the west coast
avengers going come on it's like you
already got laying in san francisco iron
man didn't have a little set up there in
iron man 3 oh and chongchi yeah yeah
there's more san francisco west coast of
heaven
or malibu man
now we open in the midst of december
with clint and his family having a
chinese meal and celebrating being back
together his daughter lila of course
opened the start of avengers end game
it's nice to see them all happy once
more as that's what clint wanted more
than anything briefly i think it's great
how she says this is the first christmas
they've had together in years as they
were of course snapped away for five or
as he wasn't now even though the trailer
hasn't been out long a lot of people
have been asking why his wife isn't
there and i'm not sure if they split up
or not after she learned about what
happened in the five years i hope not
but it is a possibility and that would
add even more weight to them not having
christmas together in the comic book run
hawkeye actually gets served divorce
papers however during the trailer he
does answer the phone and say hey babes
so i'm guessing things are still pretty
good though this mission might cause
some issues i would hate if they're
divorced at the start of this oh yeah
how much hell the guy went through to
make sure he could get his wife back his
family back it starts off end game
starts off with the loss of the barton
family the first reveal that the snap
worked is when he gets his phone call i
think it would be a such a crappy
starting off point if he's divorced i
would hate that absolutely hate that and
it would be over
of linda cardellini's talent because
she's a talented actress too like yeah
yeah i'm talking about jeremy renner of
course of course can't lose sight of the
main focus here i'm kidding you make a
good point john now could do what i
believe is broadway and we see a steve
rogers musical which appears later on in
the first look here there are several
characters from the avengers including
the chitauri hawkeye black widow thor
and loki bruce banner steve and what i
think is the hulk really nice bit of
meta commentary about the
commercialization of superheroes and how
they're pretty much in every aspect of
entertainment now this is also a nice
little callback to the first avenger as
steve of course start off by traveling
the country doing propaganda tours this
is so that people would buy war bonds
which is also what the comic character
was used for in the real world he
clearly takes them to the show and at
his hotel room catches kate bishop
masquerading as the ronin which is of
course his old identity hawkeye sends
his family off in order to go and look
for her and it's clear that the past has
caught up to him at this point now we go
to the marvel studios logo and see that
a flowing target has been superimposed
over the top of it creating a ripple i
love that this is of course hawkeye
but if we're reaching which we always
are it could be a ripple effect that has
been caused by his actions during the
snap yes i said it was a reach now for
the next part of the video i want to
talk about the comics and the brief
outline of what happens in them so that
you can see how the trailer lines up
with that series the first major enemies
that we need to talk about are the
tracks
who are led by a gangster named ivan i
said in the trailer reaction tracksuit
dracula's clint does dub them the
tracksuit draculas but they're more
commonly known as just the tracksuit
mafia okay both are correct they say bro
a lot bro and though they're not really
major threats in terms of danger they
pop up from time to time throughout the
run and attempt to kill clint in the
comics ivan wears a blue tracksuit
whilst the rest wear red and it could be
possible that the scroll we saw on
episode one of loki was entertaining
and that's why he was pulled from the
timeline
that would be awesome
clint takes matters into his own hands
takes them down and also ends up having
somewhat of an affair with a wife of a
member known as cherry clint two takes
ivan's dog who is initially called arrow
but after realizing how on the nose it
is he changes their name to lucky at one
point we even get a full issue from
their perspective and they do some
really creative stuff with it in the
series that i hope carries across to the
show i hope there's one he will be
appearing in the first season
whereas kate was already established in
the comics at this point the series will
be telling her mcu origin they have to
do at least one episode or some little
segment that cuts away to all just from
lucky's perspective if it's not the full
episode at least like one plotline yeah
just cutting back to lucky the whole
time yeah i would love to see that or a
full-on disney plus series yeah why not
everybody should get one now we also
know that vincent inofrio will be
returning his kingpin in the series this
was first recording that's sure back in
june and he's a big character in the
comic book run as well when we last saw
him he was getting beaten badly by
daredevil and he agreed not to expose
his identity as it would ruin his
reputation having lost his empire to a
blind man kingpin of course controls
through fear and whether the daredevil
show still remains canon we won't know
for a while but lots of rumors and
reports are stating that charlie cox
will return as daredevil in spiderman no
way home so it does look like it will
kind of all tied together and i really
hope that it's all connected
yeah that series was really really good
and pretty much the reason i signed up
to netflix you see that's a big part of
why i was expecting this a just from the
matt fraction comic be you know being
street level and see the fact you're
hearing that kingpin might actually be
in this especially vincent's an offrio's
take and if you guys are familiar with
daredevil which i'm hoping you guys are
familiar with that series it's an
incredibly r rated show it's a hardcore
gritty imagine this tone from the
trailer will be present in here but i
think it would weave into some more grit
especially if you're going to have
dinofrio's kingpin in there because i
wouldn't want to see him in some
light-hearted take time you know no no
no i mean he could be the thing that
brings the menace and the heavy even
more so than the tracksuit mafia it
seems like oh absolutely their legacy
now in the book a security tape leaks
showing hawkeye killing a dictator
called dookie fen and this is poised to
be sold on the black market of madrapura
which we last saw in falcon in the
winter soldier hawkeye goes out there in
order to stop it getting out and we find
out that kingpin is attempting to buy it
turns out this auction is being run by
madame mask who it's rumored will be
played by vera farmiga
bishop ends up disguising herself as her
and all hell breaks loose as they try
and get the tape before it gets out now
that's the bare bones i thought bear
from regular playing pictures
some elements taken and put into it
whilst others just stay out that's
something that's true of all marvel
shows but i definitely recommend picking
up that graphic novel run if you want to
know ahead of time the kind of stuff to
expect now we watch as hawkeye goes loki
in order to track down kate who is now
in deep with the wrong kinds of people
taking on the mantle of the ronin she
has inherited hawkeye's enemies too and
it's nice to see a character getting
some villains that aren't just tony
starks now i actually think that val
will try and recruit kate but that
she'll shut the idea down and this will
be the first inkling that the young
avengers will be formed she believes
she's the world's greatest archer but we
see that she needs some practice when
she completely destroys a clock tower
with an arrow that has a tennis ball on
it this idea of all kinds of arrows is
actually ripped directly from the comics
and in the car chase scene that happens
we see that they go through hawkeye's
armada later on in the trailer the scene
plays out almost beat for beta how it
does in the source material even down to
the car which looks exactly like how it
did in the comics during this moment the
hawkeyes are fleeing the tracksuit mafia
with cherry and ends with kate using a
boomerang arrow to take down the mafia
member that is taking them hostage you
also see the lead-up to central station
and this is of course a very important
location in the mcu as it's where the
avengers assembled for the very first
time go to the tracksuit mafia and we
see them donning their infamous red
colours now we do catch what i believe
is ivan as he's donning a slightly
different colour to the rest of them and
he also has the same facial hair that he
does in the comments true true okay
to save him and slams in head first we
get some action shots including clint
jumping out of a window running through
a restaurant like nathan drake and james
bond b raf amiga who like i said i think
is madame mask and lucky who seems to be
missing an eye lucky was actually shot
and badly damaged early on in the comics
and hawkeye ended up taking him to the
vets which this moment could be hinting
at we also get what i believe is a
historical reenactment of a fight and
yeah might be the rockefeller christmas
tree in new york never been there before
only seen it in the movies and i think i
might be right but let me know if i'm
wrong you're right uh but i also think
that moment where the reenactment's
happening i feel like that's gonna be
one of those action scenes where they're
trying to get away so then they end up
going too yeah finding themselves in a
bunch of civilians who are also play
fighting and then they gotta pretend
yeah get too serious about it and also
keep hazy so that way the yeah the hedge
men don't catch them or whatever yeah
that's the kind of vibe i got from that
moment and i hate myself for not picking
up on the car
now we then catch the car chase which as
i mentioned is taken directly from the
source material and you might notice
that the van says trust a bro
and hawkeye of course did this in the
first avengers movie and it was probably
one of his most iconic shots this
actually also pulls directly from the
first page of the comic itself and it
makes for the perfect way to end this
really fun trailer
now as for my thoughts on the teaser
this was pretty much the show that i was
the least hyped for this year however
saying that your boy is about to become
a shillionaire because i think it looks
great and it's brilliant that they've
managed to make a festive romp as the
show will be shown over christmas who
doesn't love christmas who doesn't love
bow puns absolutely everyone and i think
yeah it looks really really fun
christmas was actually a big part of the
graphic novel and though we only spent
one issue during the time period it was
such a cool setting with all the snow
drops and the people constantly moving
through the white the white panels that
really made the art look absolutely
fantastic i think another part that
makes it feel very shane black it's
different here because he's with his
family and it seems that he's still with
his wife but one thing that shane black
would say about
sending his stories during christmas is
that the ironic part about christmas as
as you know people with depression maybe
you don't know but they're people with
depression their triggers tend to go up
during the winter time because it can be
very easy to feel very like quite lonely
during the winter and so even looking at
the comic art here from the matt
fraction comic you do see like a much
more lonely hawkeye which does reflect a
lot more of what shane black tends to
use christmas for so just another thing
that adds on to it except i don't really
get that kind of uh isolated depressed
lonely sad doesn't seem like she's gonna
have time for that
that lonely yes i think this has also
been brought across to the show and is
such a good setting for everything to
take place graphic novel run is actually
really really good and it's so well put
together that i think it'll be a
brilliant series if they stick to that
it explores a lot of hawkeye's origins
which is something that we haven't
really seen in the mcu and also helps to
introduce kate as one of the young
avengers so far the mcu has clearly been
building towards them and in both one
division and fatwoods there were some
key characters that popped up to let us
know what's coming i really hope that we
explore what happened with hawkeye in
between the snap and blip as that's such
an interesting time that the mcu has
just kind of skipped over because we
haven't really had anything that's shown
us what happened in those five years and
i would love to see the character rock
that hawkeye went on after losing his
family i feel like they will because it
seems like most of the sins of his past
that are catching up to him are dealing
with his time as ronan so you would have
to make that clear as to why these
people are really coming after him you
know unless it's just a bunch of chitari
we're going after you conflict
whatsoever in terms of morality iron
man's dead cap is gone black widow's
dead we can't get thor so we're going
after you
you're the only reason to logical next
step there are a lot of things in it
that could really hit the mark overall
it left me quivering and here's to the
24th of november
really bad puns now obviously i'd love
to hear your thoughts yet i would
absolutely love it
if you dropped them in the comments
below so make sure you do thank you paul
for that video man i think we'll see
more of his backstory that i believe
what is his name he's so great and
better call saul please tell me in the
comments the actor tony something he's
amazing and better call saul he's
playing the swordsman in this show which
is uh kind of like hawk hawkeye's father
mentor figure so i imagine if you're
gonna get him in there you're definitely
gonna be exploring more of the backstory
to clint barton anyway thank you paul
subscribe to heavy spoilers subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell hit that like button last but not
least
flev doran it's tradition that we shout
you out in a marvel related video i had
to find a target of who to shout out i
aimed at that target and hit you flev
now flav you are bleeding on the ground
slowly dying out i need to resuscitate
you but also i feel like i gotta take a
photo first i aim again and i snap that
target photo boom take a photo of you
take a selfie put it on instagram be
like this is flev doran long time
patronage dying before me he upped his
pledge moments before his death that's
the kind of supporter we need all around
so thank you fleb that in your dying
moments
you increased your pledge
to 35
for the month because your your account
had been cancelled post doc that's a
reasonable amount though that's good
you're welcome
[Music]